un golpe para el equipo francés terminó
Qatar para Karim Benzema el delantero no
jugará ningún partido del mundial
estoy muy triste por Karim que había
hecho de este mundial un objetivo
importante a pesar de este nuevo golpe
para el equipo francés tengo plena
confianza en mi grupo Vamos a hacer todo
lo posible para superar el enorme reto
que nos espera
sin embargo el sábado todo había
empezado bien para el número 19 por
primera vez en doha había participado en
la formación colectiva el jugador
parecía estar en buena forma pero
rápidamente tuvo que abandonar el campo
el motivo un dolor en el cuádriceps
izquierdo por la noche llegó El
veredicto una lesión muscular que
requiere una convalecencia de tres
semanas a sus 34 años Karim Benzema
probablemente no volverá a jugar un
mundial el ganador del Balón de oro de
2022 expresó su pesar en Twitter en mi
vida nunca me he rendido pero esta noche
tengo que pensar en el equipo como
siempre lo he hecho así que la razón me
dice que deje jugar a alguien que pueda
ayudar a nuestro grupo a ser un buen
mundial Gracias por todos sus mensajes
de apoyo este mundial empieza muy mal
para el equipo francés algunos ya hablan
de la maldición del campeón las
ausencias ya eran numerosas Paul Pogba
en golocanté press del Cristofer en
cunco líder de Sam tiene que revisar sus
planes una vez más todavía tiene unas
horas para convocar a otro jugador antes
del primer partido de leblé El martes
por la noche contra Australia